là vous allez voir ils vont chacun se
retourner et chanter une chanson c'est
un ballon à l'hélium moyens wes dégonfle
j'allais moi ça fait rien ça fait la
même voie allez-y attention de libé
délivrer les étoiles me tendent les bras
gab et laurent gbagbo qu elle ça marche
super bien
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce qu'on essaierait offrant de
faire de vote et serait tombé qui les
connaissent et au four de cette boîte
scellée sarine dans ce les sardines si
les lourds sera donc amputé chante
chante là l'autre la première classe
moussu premier bouquet qui s est pas
dense faille entre la barre aléas les
maillots de leurs bohème et prenez en
plus mathieu aspire mon dieu après
différents
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
vous avez chanté ça c'est bon ça promet
qui m'est venue production c'est comme
ça que ma blonde ravissante autre chose
journée à clairefontaine
allez c'est parti et mathieu aller vite
oui bah oui ok là bas connemara et j'en
peux plus de lui en fait on a tous
l'habitude vers des zones boisées avec
limite je suis bien qu'à tomber la
mémoire boda terre au pays des
merveilles il me semble que pénible si
on pouvait dire grosse room qui viennent
récupérer ses testicules c'est mon
compère suture moi j'ai pas mal jugé on
n'arrête pas de jugement à y arriver là
il devait faire une chanson orientale
faire des actes de pillage et 6 étaient
jetés à la rue
ça fait parler
tout tout tout vous saurez tout sur mon
désir a laissé filer nous on est y met
mais vous êtes lourd tout non mais il
est toujours lourd le mec c'est ça qui
lie c'est impossible est aussi lourd que
ça venait là là là bas attendait déjà
qu'ils se faisaient nous interpréter
très pin sur la route est sur la route
tu verras bien comme je brutt c'est pas
ça les paroles c'est bien ça fait rien
c'est bien y'a qu'ça êtes déjà pourquoi
pas ça vous est déjà arrivé de bonté ou
de sur la route c est vous avez déjà
fait l'amour dans la voiture oui ben oui
l'étudiant pendant oui mais il
conduisait bon vous êtes salarié avec un
autre mec est un symbole et de freins
par contre on est parti alors ça moi je
sais pas bien faire alors il a déjà fait
la voix non plus piqué sur la semana sur
ma route et verra bientôt au japon
[Musique]
[Rires]
il suffit ça suffit
merci tiens bertrand chamerois garcia me
ward a donné son droit à la radio
vendredi ainsi sa chronique est pas
bonne on vous donnera son nouveau numéro
en gare des cars et gâteaux djibril
cissé qui est là ça mahmoud jibril
jibril arrivé aux instants bon série
sera avec nous en touche pas à mon pote
il nous dira tout sur danse avec escales
et vous grosse pression si je vous le
dis si sa chronique n'est pas bonne on
donnera encore le nouveau numéro de
bertrand mais je suis assez confiant
faisons comme ça un cheval j'enlève le
dit mais ça va pas bien la touche à tout
[Rires]
[Musique]